hey what's up guys my name is China
welcome back to my Ray tracing series
got a quick one for you today see what I
did there quick one because we're going
to be making this faster today now last
time we talked about emission and
emissive materials I'll have the video
linked up there in case you haven't
watched it yet highly recommend you do
it's kind of a good summary of what
we've achieved so far in this series so
if you have if you're kind of trying to
get back into this then it's a good
place to rekindle the series right so at
the moment this is what we're dealing
with uh if we just launched the
application we've got this we did make a
bit of a different scene last time but
we just did that by manipulating these
controls speaking of which we probably
should introduce a way to kind of save
scenes and maybe customize things like
the Skylight that's probably something I
want to do fairly soon I just don't know
how it fits into this series because
it's going to be mostly like just an
episode about UI and like serialization
and stuff so I'm I don't know but anyway
uh you can see while I've been talking
this has accumulated nicely and it looks
pretty good now the frame time here
actually isn't too bad but you can see
that we're getting like around if I just
pause it for like a second we're getting
around 20 milliseconds and also 19.5
milliseconds per frame and then you know
like moving around the camera is not too
bad I mean it's spiking maybe up to like
25 milliseconds of course it's going to
entirely depend on what your setup is
like for your scene if you've got more
spheres if they're potentially bigger
spheres and they cause more bounces
you're going to obviously slow down that
kind of frame time but the main reason
why I even wanted to kind of come in
here and speed this up is because the
next major thing that we're going to be
exploring is like the specular component
of all of these lighting calculations
what you saw in that kind of rendering
just there was diffuse only now specular
is an entirely different ball game I
would say it's definitely more
complicated than just diffuse and that's
definitely going to bring down our
performance going to make things a
little bit harder to kind of work with
and of course one of the goals of this
series is we want to keep things kind of
model as real time so we end up having
these kind of episodes where we go in
and we're like us let's just make this
faster so I was thinking about what the
kind of slow parts were in general I
think we kind of know from the last time
we sped things up that this kind of
random number calculation that's really
that was the bottleneck and the way that
we're actually generating these random
numbers is by again using like this C
plus plus kind of random number
generation engine which is definitely
not uh particularly performant we had an
episode a while back where we added this
thread local keyword to the random
engine I'll leave the link up there in
case you want to check it out that
definitely sped things up because when
we added multi-threading in the first
place and this wasn't exactly thread
safe it was causing its own performance
issues for us and that definitely helped
but the presence of this engine in the
first place presents a few different
issues again the first one being
performance it's not really like the
random generation that we might need
either it's important to consider the
fact that like at the end of the day
we're creating images and of course we
want them to be realistic but it's kind
of like you know why are we even using
random numbers we're not using random
numbers where we're like really really
pedantic about that kind of statistical
kind of random distribution and it's
kind of like maybe like the lottery I
mean I don't know how the lottery Works
to be honest but I I assume that like
it's really important there that things
are kind of random them because if
they're predictable in any kind of way
that breaks everything right people are
going to game the system take advantage
and it's not kind of fair uh Ray tracing
different entirely right like I mean
does it even matter if these numbers are
truly random yes and no because if we
wind up tracing the same Parts over and
over again because there's a predictable
sequence that's wrong because we're not
going to evaluate as many different
light paths as we could and what that
means is we will get a noisier image we
will get a worse result over time and I
mean it will probably end up being a
waste of time if we keep kind of just
recalculating the same results where we
could be tracing New Paths and figuring
out new kind of you know light areas and
similarly the distribution of these
random values is also going to kind of
matter because that can affect the
quality of our rays but again we're not
trying to be uniformly random anyway
we're trying to weight things in a
certain way that is going to contribute
more important samples so that's kind of
the first problem with this kind of like
random situation that we have right the
fact that it's not very it's it's slow
the second problem is that clearly this
is part of the C plus plus like standard
library now our end goal for this series
like I mean really the end game is to
run this but on our GPU using Vulcan Ray
tracing right so we want to be able to
use like the ray tracing cores inside
our GPU and like the Vulcan Ray tracing
API to actually just generate this image
so that's kind of like the end game but
I mean even like the Intermediate game
the middle game I'll say which I'm not
100 sure if we'll end up doing it
depends on what you guys want really but
I was gonna take like this code and just
move it onto the GPU but just have it
run as a compute Shader so not full-on
like Ray tracing shaders but just as a
compute Shader in Vulcan now when slash
if we do that but either way for the end
game you know when we start running this
on the GPU in shaders we clearly aren't
going to be able to use this because
this isn't like this is part of the
zebra standard library and glsl or like
shading languages in general they don't
have like random number generators and
so my point is we're going to have to
switch to a different system anyway and
obviously like the functions that we use
to Generate random numbers or pseudo
random numbers obviously is what I'm
talking about it's all pseudo-random I
mean they're like intrinsically those
functions are kind of built with like no
Global state in mind or anything because
they're used in shaders which of course
are dispatched like in parallel so
they're actually really useful and
really compatible to use with what we
have right now and it's as simple as
just dropping them in so that's what
we're going to do today we're going to
take a look at a way that we can
generate pseudo-random numbers with a
rather simple function just by having
like an input seed doing some stuff to
it and then getting like a kind of a
random-ish result that will be good
enough for what we intend to use it for
and that will hopefully speed up our
rendering but before we jump into that I
want to thank brilliant.org for
sponsoring this video now brilliant.org
is an amazing website filled with lots
and lots of really high quality courses
on various stem topics it's my go-to
place to Direction you guys if you want
to learn math all the way from beginner
level so if you're like if you've never
done math before be scared of math
whatever it may be their Everyday Math
course fantastic really good place to
start but then also getting into some
more advanced topics that will be useful
for this series such as linear algebra
and calculus why brilliant so many
reasons first of all each lesson is
bite-sized it's small enough that you
don't have to allocate a whole lot of
time to just get through it secondly the
way that they present it is just really
kind of fun like I genuinely enjoy
learning and going through their content
and really I think the reason for that
is because they present everything very
visually and not just visually but also
interactively like they have these
widgets that you can play with that show
you how like the numbers work and how
the thing that you're learning works and
learning math visually like I feel like
that's pretty much a requirement I mean
think about why we even use graphs in
math like we could just look at numbers
but graphs tell us much more don't they
and the reason for that is because we're
not like we're not computers like
numbers are cool but it often makes a
lot more sense to kind of see everything
visually and that is how brilliant
teaches you now brilliant at the moment
have a 30 day free trial so you can just
jump in for 30 days and check out
everything that they have to offer for
free just go to brilliant.org the
channel link will be in the description
below brilliant have also been nice
enough to offer the first 200
subscribers 20 off an annual membership
huge thank you as always to brilliant
for sponsoring this video alright so how
are we going to Generate random numbers
there are a few different functions we
could use here a really really popular
one that honestly I've seen used
everywhere is something called Wang hash
I'll put it up on the screen for you I
feel like this has been like one of the
go-to random functions and shaders that
I've seen in a lot of different places
most recently I've seen it in some
Nvidia samples I'll briefly explain how
a function like this works basically you
can see that it returns like a uint and
it takes in a uint which is the seed so
it takes in some kind of seed and it
does all of these operations to it and
then it returns it so the idea here is
that you start off with some kind of
unique seed you need to have some some
thing that identifies that shaded
dispatch in a unique way so the idea is
if you were using this in like a
fragment Shader or a computer you could
for example just use like the pixel ID
obviously with the computer here we're
assuming that we're running it across an
image or something so we have that kind
of pixel ID so like in our Ray Tracer if
we take a look at per pixel like it
could literally be this x and y
coordinate kind of like we're using here
right but then we're also accumulating
this over time so we wouldn't just want
to use like this right because that
means that every frame when we're trying
to accumulate a new image we would get
the same result over and over again but
we can kind of break it up by using this
Frame index so if we combine like the
frame index with this and then also it
depends how many bounces we have because
each bounce should kind of be unique
hopefully you're kind of getting the
point like we can put together we can
craft a number here that is going to be
almost like a unique index for that
particular path or array and once we
have that we can fit it in as the seed
to this function it's going to do a
bunch of random stuff to it and then
spit out a uint now that uint is going
to be basically a random number we
obviously want to deal with random
floats so we're going to just have to
divide that by like the max value of a
uint which is like 4.2 something billion
and then we'll get a value between zero
and one now we're not going to use Wang
hash specifically because Wang hash uh
is both a little bit more complicated
than it needs to be it's more Cycles
more operations and then also it's not
very statistically distributed well
instead there's something else that we
can use called PCG this is both like a
prng function and a hash function
because it's so good as far as I'm aware
it's Superior to Wang hash in every way
both in performance but also massively
in statistical distribution I'll link
some articles below that kind of talk
about this they're basically my source
for this that's what I'm basing my
claims on so if you want to read a
little bit more links will be in the
description below okay so now that we
kind of understand the theory let's just
go ahead and implement this I'm just
going to go up to this render dot CPP
file and just implement it here under
the details section I kind of like the
idea of almost treating this like a
Shader ish so that like everything is
just in this one file and you can find
everything you need here I don't want to
bounce around too much so let's go ahead
and write out this function PCG hash
okay and I mean that's kind of it like
if you look at this in terms of what
this is actually doing so it's taking in
that kind of input seed it's multiplying
it and adding some like magic numbers
we're doing some bit shifting and some
zoring this is the extent of that random
number generation right so in terms of
like what our CPU and then later our GPU
has to do this is it's all here and it's
going to be massively more simple than
this whole random engine setup that we
used to have now obviously this gets us
a uint a random uint we are looking for
a float between zero and one because we
want it to kind of like work the same
way that this float works like this
random float that we used to be using as
part of like vec3 and then this in unit
sphere function so you can see what this
does it just takes a distribution from
that random engine casts it to a flow so
this is just going to be like a uint and
then we're dividing it by un32 Max
numerical elements un32 Max so the
maximum possible value of a un-32t and
obviously casting that to a float as
well so that we get a float division one
of these needs to be a float for that or
both and this obviously winds up giving
us a float between zero and one so if we
were to implement that here we could
just write static float I don't know
let's just write random floats now what
we're going to take in our seed and I'm
going to take it in as a reference here
because we actually want to kind of
override it so we're not we're never
going to call this function outside of
this function but you can see that this
takes in that input and then returns it
and that return value basically becomes
our new input or our new seed so to make
that work I'm actually going to set seed
equal to PCG hash seed right so what I'm
doing is I'm overwriting that value of C
to something else now because it's a
reference it means that if I call this
random float function and I pass in this
kind of state every single time I can
just repeatedly call it and I'll keep
getting around of numbers and the reason
why it's parameterized like this of
course is just to get rid of this whole
Global State situation we don't want
that because obviously our algorithms
here are running in parallel and on the
GPU they're going to be even more
parallel basically because here we're
running I don't know how many cores we
have like eight cores or whatever on the
GPU we have like eight and a half
thousand cores well at least on my 30
80. so it's a bit of a different ball
game and we definitely want this to be
not dependent on each other hence the
kind of parameterization but this is
basically the state of our random number
generator now that we've done that all
we have to do is like we've generated
that random number it is the seed
basically so let's go ahead and just
divide seed by if we go back here uh
this so it's obviously the same data
type uh the alternative I still don't
know which one I prefer honestly but of
course there's also this macro called
un32 Max
um and to save this is like more of a c
way of doing it but you can see that you
still get like the maximum value as an
unsigned in 32 right so that it's the
same thing and you can actually see that
in this implementation at least in the
limb it's kind of Library just put this
over here so you can see this is the
limits header file it's just returning
that as well I mean it's not the 32 Max
it's the unit Max but it's just that so
use either of these honestly this is the
more C plus plus way of doing it because
it's in a c plus header as opposed to a
c header but whatever I don't know if
it's worth me including stuff like that
by the way maybe this waste everyone's
time but I don't know I just feel like I
should mention something when I write
certain code and I think about why I've
written it all right anyway that's done
so now we just have a way to Generate
random flow between zero and one now if
we look at what we were doing though
with this kind of in unit sphere
function right what that did is it
generated a vect3 between negative one
and one which just cause float but then
multiplies it by Max minus Min and all
that to get it into a different space
but really that just calls float three
times for The X Y and Z component and
then we normalize it so if I just take
this function we're going to go back
here I'm going to paste it in and then
what I'm going to do is I'm just going
to pull glm vac 3 here we're just going
to make a new vac 3 here that's going to
call random float now we'll need some
kind of seed as an input so I'm going to
go ahead and put that in here we'll call
random flow at three times but we're
going to multiply it by two and subtract
one so that's just going to get it
between that kind of negative one to one
space instead of zero to one and we
obviously have to do that per component
so we'll copy and paste that a couple
more times and that's it if I just drop
this down so it's a little bit more
visible this is what we've created do
something fancy like that and because
this seed gets written to by this
function each function call here is in
fact going to give us a different value
it's not like we need to write to seed
ourselves it gets passed by reference
okay so that's it that's our in unit
sphere function which gives us a vector
obviously just kind of more or less
uniformly distributed along the sphere's
surface pointing into some kind of
direction we are going to eventually
change this by the way obviously this is
just like an easy kind of hack way of
getting this to work we'll probably
change this soon to be like a more
serious I guess way of doing this maybe
like a cosine weighted distribution
instead of this kind of random one at
the moment okay so I I would love to
compare the performance here so instead
of just changing this straight up I'm
actually going to go to our Walnut app
here uh and actually no let's go back
for a second let's go into our render
settings here and I'll make a Boolean
here called slow random we'll just leave
that as true uh by default then we'll go
to Walnut app and we'll find the place
that we do all of our imgui stuff so we
have a checkbox here called accumulate
let's duplicate that and make a check
box called slow random and we'll just
obviously get that to manipulate the
slow random variable inside our render
settings and then back here I'm just
going to make an if M settings slow
random we'll do that otherwise let's do
our new fast way which again all we're
going to do is replace this existing
function with utils random float now the
seed the most important kind of part of
this so let's go ahead and write seed
for now we obviously haven't made that
yet so let's go up and I'm going to
create a seed here
so this seed variable I'm just going to
set that to be this to begin with now
I'm going to take seed I'm going to
multiply it by the frame index
are over here and I'm not exactly going
for like 100 uh unique index per frame
but this will be good enough and then
over here we're just going to add in
that bounce kind of Index right I is
like our bounce index so what this is
basically going to mean is we're going
to have a unique seed per pixel per
frame of like accumulation and frame
index by the way starts at one so don't
worry about this making it zero across
all pixels for the first frame it won't
and we have a unique seed kind of per
bounce now it is possible that they're
going to overlap between certain pixels
like if if this is like pixel index one
we times it by one we get one we double
it we get two like there's going to be
some overlap so this isn't perfect but
it will be good enough all right that
sounds that's getting getting bright and
warm
I like it all right anyway
um yeah so that should be good enough
let's just run this all right so
hopefully you can see that last round of
time here is
um like 15 milliseconds I got slow
random checked let me uncheck that
okay so that hasn't worked random in
unit sphere obviously is what I meant so
let's hit F5 let's see what happens
hopefully this is correct all right so
here we have around 17 milliseconds per
frame with the slow random obviously
it's kind of variable here and if I
uncheck that you can see
we go down to around 13 milliseconds per
frame and of course this is going to
depend on how we kind of move around
uh it's gonna definitely depend on our
scene but the cool thing is like as I
kind of zoom in here and I go between
the two randoms the distribution you can
see is actually like I mean I can't
really tell
the difference and hopefully you can
kind of see the difference here in
performance so here we are sitting
around 10 milliseconds or so
would slow around them on and then if I
shut it off you can see we never really
hit that 10 so on
off
now as I mentioned though this is based
off of a sequence of predictable numbers
what that means and one way that we can
see that clearly is if I uncheck
accumulate
this doesn't change frame to frame but
if I check slow random it does that's
because we are generating completely
different random numbers with their own
kind of State per thread every single
time we go through that kind of slower
random path whereas here we are going
through the same sequence of numbers
every single time so you just have to be
aware of the potential consequences of
that but you can see that if I do check
accumulate like the difference between
these two is absolutely not apparent and
we definitely will be changing it
slightly as well in the future of course
so I hope you guys enjoyed this episode
if you did please don't forget to hit
the like button now whilst this
performance Improvement might not be
that dramatic the cool thing that we've
done here is that we're generating our
own random numbers like we don't rely on
the C plus standard Library anymore and
the reason why that's useful is because
it's going to make our lives a lot
easier when we do in fact move to the
GPU in the future thank you all for
watching I'll see you next time goodbye